hi I'm Greg I'm John listen guys check
it any covenant trailer number two why
talk anymore I don't know no reason he's
good he's all sacrificed so much to be
here and be a part of this thing we're
doing it made up this couple the first
ever large-scale colonization mission
and everyone back on earth is really
grateful for hard work
new courage
like great lesson Harvey
this is week well you have to point here
with expansion distortionary
to planet
[Music]
you know we came back what nothing no
birds no animals nothing
little joke or the what happened here
away away Billy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh daddy that you know work look fun
what are some of that's practical the
one at the end did not look very
practical but the one in the hallway
could have been yeah might have been I
mean actually I got it like I feel like
they probably got to have some practical
I feel like we'll see both I would be
actually very upset if we didn't see any
practical is even more wonder what
planet they're going to I don't know was
that's the same u-shaped ship from from
prometheus yeah that was intense trailer
yeah it was like an intense thrill ride
I mean was what I really liked about the
clip and they released recently above
the characters but I was like I feel
rather invested in these guys actually I
feel like these is gonna be a good crew
to watch you know deteriorated over time
and when they go to this planet I was
like I want an interesting environment
to put the next Alien movie in yeah
because this is like a dark tropical
paradise like if the title is calling
like how they originally wanted to call
like alien paradise or something we need
go there it's like this was beautiful
it's like a nature kind of surrounding
for its roars gate and mountains and
yeah and I haven't seen a Lee movie take
place there like that yet at least there
are parts of this that remind me of the
at least like the broad strokes of
Prometheus the whole like ooh cool first
landing on the planet sequence and like
odd is uncharted into place but as I
remember the previous planet it was a
lot more like flat yeah exactly so yeah
like this yeah there's like trees and
the week they were talking about it was
like agriculture had formed is like
people had lived there but now no one
there there's no life ones and they come
across with one life yeah killing
everyone in the [ __ ] that [ __ ]
xenomorph dude that was intense
this is yeah this movie does look really
an intent every time he comes back to
this like it looks really reading who
the designs are cool like the ideas are
engrossing you know and I like their
calves this feels closer to what when
really got first announced before
Prometheus when he was talking about how
he wants to you know do an alien pretty
cool and then it turned into Prometheus
over time he's like it's not exactly an
alien pretty one it wasn't it wasn't
exactly an alien prequel Prometheus and
this looks more like what we all thought
he would be doing when we first heard he
would be doing an alien prequel the same
year along those lines because it has an
up-to-date gritty look like it has a
beautiful dirty Grace and a Matar fee
throughout yeah is that gray it's very
stark like all these movies feel very
stark yeah I guess now I'm just
interested in like where the actual
story is going to go yes like this is it
Elise again the broad strokes this
doesn't look entirely different from
Prometheus to me it just looks like
different planet Prometheus well right
now it looks like Prometheus meets the
first alien movie it's like a crew or
they stumble across this planet and
there's like all these [ __ ] eggs in a
shitty billy club looks like he'll be
the first person that the you know the
squid alien or whatever latches onto him
and the nice hunger based huggers and
chest bursts and all that [ __ ] so it
looks like a combination of the first
alien meet Prometheus in terms of like
plot and visual look and intention bill
Prometheus was like the similar plot to
alien but it wasn't about the xenomorph
in the eggs and all that [ __ ] it looked
like didn't want to me you didn't want
to do that but this one is directly
doing that now you know yeah that's what
I mean about how this feels like it this
is what really Scott what I thought of
what I'm really caught first announced
way back when that you would be doing a
prequel I'm definitely interested to see
this I'm having trouble being like
completely excited about it just because
like I know what Prometheus was like and
I know how cool that trailer looked and
I know that Ridley Scott is enormous
right now but just going off this
trailer this looks really cool like the
images are striking and it looks scary
and vicious it looks like a great thrill
ride to me it doesn't look like it's
going to be breaking new ground
necessarily I feel like you can still be
very exciting very intense very
suspenseful some great effects
but in terms of like plot and
that's been one thing that kind of sucks
about it Prometheus set up this world of
exploration and gave us no manners
didn't accessor a daily wrinkle of the
vision up yeah and here it's like all
right we're gonna can the exploration
stuff we're going to go right back into
Meghan is about alien right away so I
feel like it can be a sharp thrill ride
but at the same time it is a little bit
of a wet better they're not feeling much
of like what about all the questions you
guys left them present permit to guess
you know yeah yeah that's another thing
I'm wondering about cousin they say that
maybe this is a twist now or something
but didn't they say there were two David
and then no we were past was going to be
somewhere in here yeah I think so
Michael fought fenders David this is
different David this is a different date
but I think his like disembodied David
also comes back I think that people yeah
I don't know they say a lot of things I
always want to be a child change the
billion times what they wanted to make
it about has changed a bunch see I hope
that we're getting it straight for alien
moving up that's what it looks like yeah
I'm straight bored alien foot
I hope they nail it because the thing is
like you know this is the second time
Ridley Scott has returned to one of his
babies we can debate and give passes to
Prometheus or whatnot but I just really
hope that this proves to be worthwhile
for you to come back to this mega thing
you know with two installments at least
that are agreeably great you know like
to stand out from other of these kinds
of movies it would be a bummer if this
didn't also stand out I have a good at
James Franco's gonna die very early you
don't see him in this trailer and it's
barely the clip did you like it sitting
out there like completely unrelated of
intelligence right we're going to dive
very early on I don't think Danny
McBride will die in that scene where
he's like bashing at the after whether
Xena lobe is bashing at the window
he'll do some kind of cool rage maybe
we'll die eventually in the movie oh
yeah because he's the pilot with a
cowboy hat today I'm gonna you've got to
do something maybe vaguely heroic and
then duck you know I hope they
circumvent some of these districts yeah
it looks cool it doesn't exactly look
like 100 percent unique in terms of its
storytelling it looks like it's ambition
that's kind of lowered and they're going
for more of a direct straightforward to
alien movie it gave me this the spatial
in the sensory entry
the Prometheus trailer did it just
didn't also start going but what about
life where did we come for like its it
seems like they're playing a little more
straightforward and maybe that's a good
thing yeah because I think it didn't pan
out too well for me it's nothing it's
primary because it didn't [ __ ] how do
they had any answers and I think that I
know why it didn't turn out well I would
love to hear what happened to that
instead of them kind of [ __ ] some
answers I'd rather just have them do
something like this then I guess yeah
because we were all excited when really
Scott returned the alien the man created
alien is returning and then we didn't
get that and this is that yes is the
return to alien I hope it is that looks
like the Prometheus looks like ye and
return to alien but but I'll you know
you also want the return to like the
caliber of alien yeah not just Oh Xena
more because anybody can make that movie
I hope they really paid attention to
what happened was from easiest because
that's what still worries me about this
is when they started talking about
Prometheus Eagle really Scott's actually
gonna do it the amount of times the news
chain just talked about a million times
like I just don't know who that came
from and and why and you never get the
straight story this is a badass trailer
I hope it's about us it looks like it
was just one genome work but with all
the eggs and [ __ ] I bet that's going to
be probably a couple of that come out
they will probably see if you well there
is at least one creature that didn't
look like your traditional xenomorph too
so I imagine there at least be a couple
creature moments yeah they're pretty
cool I'm nervously excited about about
this I mean even at CGI shots of them
were scary like I said at the end shot
oh yeah that's my favorite thing about
always up fishes you know what we got
here how fast and [ __ ] yeah it does look
like they're really bothering with a lot
of disasters stuff to like put you there
and like how fast and claustrophobic
these you know spaceship hallways and
things are almost like a creature
slasher vibe you know yeah like this
booze creatures hunting us down we got
to get with man well what'd you guys
think your new the channel you can
subscribe as a real rejects
I'm Greg this is John I'm rich Jerry and
put her Instagram
social media manager of Blum house and
the real rejects tap the first person I
requested it
leggo juice Studios is up like this
matically go okay panic lego movie I
don't know I'm not sure Jojo just so you
just sway looks like it was chatting
it's 31 so let's do it let's do it let's
look we're going to judge your channel
right in front of you Lego who
interesting as Lego videos interesting
Hispanic Lego videos Lego x-men
apocalypse yeah shout